stephen cohen is professor emeritus of
russian studies and politics at nyu and
princeton a contributing editor the
nation maybe the most famous russia
scholar in the united states he joins us
tonight professor thanks for coming on
so am i missing i just want to be
absolutely clear cuz i think this helps
inform how we see this investigation are
you aware of any other investment in the
Trump campaign and the Russian
government other than the dossier no
none but there are two documents that
became the foundational sources for the
Kremlin gate narrative it was first the
steel dossier which surely informed the
so-called intelligence community
assessment in January of to 17 we were
told that was the judgment of seventeen
intelligence agencies it now turns out
to have been the judgment of no
intelligence agencies just a few guys at
the top so that is all that's ever been
produced and it's not credible what
about we know that that dossier was at
least part of the rationale for the
warrant that allowed the feds to spy on
Carter page do you think that other
people in Trump's orbit during the
campaign were spied on by the federal
government oh I don't know in the
article I just published in the nation I
asked that question we need to find out
I mean why did they for example get a
warrant on Carter page who on the very
surface of it is no threat to American
national security and then on Paul
Manafort we might assume they did it
because they thought these two men would
be close even in the same room with
Donald Trump and wanted to surveil him
but let me just make one point Carter
Tucker the the what interests me is not
who paid for the dossier we know it was
the Clinton campaign right where Steele
got this information and in the article
I write I suggest that it's highly
unlikely he got it from his so-called
connections in the Kremlin now there's a
big attempt underway to rehabilitate
Steele on the front page of The
Washington Post today there's a story
that portrays him as a kind of character
out of a John Macari a spy novel and he
may well be an anguish man without a
purpose in life
retired for some reason at a very early
age and for hire so this is the guy who
now enters our life and is used and that
larger question that comes to my mind
but you know the answer better than I do
is how many branches of government do we
actually have I was taught we had three
but what's been going on above with the
intelligence services and not only the
FBI raises a question if there's a
fourth branch of government that's
influencing not only our politicians but
because they were leaking to the media
what we voters think when we go to vote
do you think that the information in the
dossier and you're a credible person to
ask this of do you think it's credible I
mean do you think it's real do you think
it came from real sources it can be
verified it hasn't yet been but do you
think it will be or does it made up well
we could didn't did you know we have to
deconstruct it some of it is true
because he got it from open sources from
newspapers and raise it was it really a
mystery when I was in Moscow over the
years
I knew Donald Trump wanted to build a
hotel in Moscow it was widely discussed
it was in the papers you need to hire a
guy for the money they paid steel to
tell you that we knew for example that
the oil company that purported he was
going to pay Carter paid zillions of
dollars if he would remove sanctions
that had actually been placed by the
European Union not the Americans it's a
preposterous tale but it was known in
Russia in the newspapers that they were
going to privatize 15% of that oil
company so you could have sat wherever
it was stealing or his associates live
and read the Russian press and gotten
about 50% of that information because a
lot of our intelligence comes from
newspapers that's the shocking truth as
you well know professor thank you for
that I appreciate it